All the way from Trenchtown, Jamaica, Bob Marley!
Come on!
Yeah, this is my identity.
It is mentioned in the Bible that there shall be music,...
...that all people shall play and dance, and sing.
What other music could that be?
Reggae.
We come from such a humble beginning,...
...my father would always take us about to Trenchtown.
...would never lock his car; that's like saying you don't trust people.
I was the one that he would call to get women out of his dressing room.
I became his guardian angel.
"All your parents do is smoke and play music."
Nobody wanted their children around us.
The most important thing culturally that was happening in Jamaica at that time...
...was Bob Marley exploding on to the world stage.
There was that sense that he's about to be massive.
My life is only important if I can help plenty of people.
In my life, there's just me and my own security.
There'd be no wanting.
My life is the people.
Are you a rich man?
You have a lot of possessions?
Possessions make you rich?
I don't have those types of riches; my riches are life.
Love, prosperity: be with us all.
Yeah, Rastafari.
Rasta.